that is a truism of politics that
hypocrisy is always newsworthy hypocrisy
is always news worthy if somebody is a
religious christian and then they have
an affair this is a newsworthy event
according to the media if there's a
politician who's right wing that
politician turns out to be gay really
really newsworthy according to the media
but there is one area of hypocrisy that
is just not newsworthy to the media like
truly not newsworthy and that of course
is if you are a socialist who's
extremely wealthy and gives very little
charity if you are that person then
hypocrisy just doesn't play a part
hypocrisy is never a problem because
after all you're calling for societal
change you yourself don't have to abide
by any of those rules because some
animals are more equal than other
animals
but
the socialist has the benefit of the
bargain because you get to be a
socialist as you want to like bernie
sanders and then you get to have a lake
house you just be a millionaire while
proclaiming that billionaires i'm paying
to flush up
okay so this issue has become relevant
over the course of the past couple of
days because a guy named hassan
who i believe used to be a young turks
guy i don't really know that much about
him
he apparently is a socialist twitch
streamer
there's a big article the glowing
profile about him in new york magazine
titled streaming with hassan the
aoc of twitch i'm a political
commentator with like stans okay well in
the past few months
hassan it turns out
has been revealed to be a very wealthy
person which good for him he has a lot
of folks who are following him over
twitch that is his that is his
prerogative and i'm i'm glad for him
that he's been able to build a following
but
a couple of times in the last month it's
been revealed that this
out and out socialist i mean this is
what he calls himself
that
he is um a very wealthy man quote hassan
was in a rage a million tabs were
pinched together like sardines at the
top of his browser his jittery cursor
balanced between them summoning news
work network news kyron's youtube brands
viral tweets and tick tock memes the
day's trending topic who is 30 had
purchased a 2.7 million house in west
hollywood an ordinary twitch streamer's
housing wouldn't make headlines but over
the past five years pecar has become one
of the most prominent socialist pundits
in america the controversy about the
purchase had made it to fox news and
breitbart and was prepared to take
on the interlopers who logged on to see
the fireworks quote the only reason my
house is expensive is because of the
area i live in he growled are you guys
really that stupid
um
that doesn't that's not even a response
to the charge the charge is that for a
socialist you seem to be spending large
my friend it doesn't mean like you could
have there a lot of places that are not
in west hollywood that don't cost 2.7
million dollars they're all over the
united states
you can get yourself a tiny little shack
and live yourself the henry david
thoreau lifestyle for probably 30 grand
somewhere
2.7 million bucks a lot of money
i don't see you handing that out to all
of the immigrated workers in the marxist
social construct
right that's the charge and his response
is well of course it's expensive around
here this is west hollywood which of
course is not a response
said three weeks later quote as
long as you don't defend your core
values as long as you're still speaking
truth to power then ephem yes speaking
truth to power is being the guy who buys
the three million dollar house and does
interviews with new york magazine and
then jabbers about how the rich don't
pay their fair share because i don't
give a bleep i'm doing this in the least
exploitative way you functionally effing
can
really
he says it's my labor
i'm the one who's streaming for 10 hours
welcome to capitalism my dude
it's my labor
yes who's labor
so in other words you bet on yourself
you've done really well and you believe
that you deserve to keep the proceeds of
that labor but aren't you exploiting all
the people who are engaged in commerce
with you after all what service of value
are you providing them you are twitch
streaming video games
is that a vital social service what
makes that service significantly more
important socially speaking from a
marxist perspective than the guy who
picks up the garbage why doesn't he own
a 2.7 million home in west hollywood
according to new york magazine is
a twitch streamer who spends every day
in front of a camera speaking to his 1.5
million followers
but unlike most of the platform's top
users mostly talks politics he
trawls through twitter and roses bad
takes from career right-wing
correspondents like ben shapiro and
tucker carlson he breaks down hawkish
new york times op-eds line by line
steadily working himself into a frothy
fury it's free associative and
open-ended i have an accelerated version
of brain worms he says i'm literally
always online i'm consuming media
non-stop
tune in to a stream watch him
condemn the civilian death toll in
afghanistan an hour later he may move on
to revisiting his favorite wwe feuds
fans don't need to have studied marks to
understand where is coming from
um
well
they they might have to remarks to
understand why is violating core
tenets of
marxism he looms over his streaming rig
at six foot four broad shoulder and a
silver bracelet and paint speckled
cowboy bebop shirt gnashing a cut of
nicotine gum against his molars on
election night from the same room he
hosted nearly 230 000 concurrent viewers
making him the sixth most watched
election live stream across the internet
a month prior he broadcast playing the
video game among us with representatives
aoc and ilhan omar
okay and and then later in this little
sop piece
he talks about the tax the rich stress
that aoc wore
and here's what he said quote i think
the met gala is a disgusting gluttonous
exercise and if given the opportunity to
go i'd do it in an effing heartbeat i'm
sorry everyone would why wouldn't you
want to hang out with frank ocean
they're not going to the effing davos
summit well but
yes they are what do you think the met
gala is
it is a bunch of rich liberals who are
getting together to feed themselves for
their rich liberalism
again
the media are not interested in calling
out hypocrisy the reason i say that is
because this story was now updated okay
so there was a twitch
data
a twitch data leak
here's how it was reported from the new
york times twitch the live video site
popular with gamers said on wednesday it
had endured a data breach that security
researchers believe may have provided
sweeping insight into the platform's
computer code security vulnerabilities
and payments to its content creators
twitch which is owned by amazon
confirmed it had been breached hours
after a user posted what the user
claimed was an enormous trove of twitch
data onto the anonymous message board
website 4chan
the user said the file contained among
other items the history of twitch's
source code proprietary software
development kits and an unreleased
competitor to steam and online game
store and programs and a list of the
amount of money that each of the sites
that streamers has earned since 2019.
find out how much your favorite streamer
is really making the user posted jeff
bezos paid 970 million bucks for this
we're giving it away for free again
we're going through this new york times
piece about twitch buried way down in
this article way down
in this article
is this little revelation quote
according to the list of earnings which
could not be independently verified some
notable personalities had made millions
of dollars since
2019. one streamer hassan
anticipated people getting angry about
the amount of money the list said he had
made
just woke up to some fun news he tweeted
can't wait for people to be mad at me
about my publicly available sub count
again and then he trended he said bro
come on
okay so it never says in here what
exactly hassan made okay now let's
just put it this way
it makes headlines every time a
conservative signs a contract
okay if
the irs information of conservative
commentators were leaked you think that
wouldn't be front page news it would
absolutely be front page news and it
wouldn't be about the leak or how the
leak came about
what it would be about was the amount of
money that everybody was making how do
we know this because the front page of
every major newspaper this week was
about what international figures made
via irs documents that were leaked
right and other sort of financial
documents that were leaked it was the
content that was the story
so what exactly did these leaked
documents show that
hassan apparently rakes in about 3
million bucks a year by doing his switch
streaming
which is a lot of money
it's a lot more money than your average
day-to-day
marxist
lower class worker
right the social class of people who are
doing the actual labor that is being
exploited
why isn't that the headline the reason
that isn't the headline is because
socialists are never held to their own
standards they are never held to their
own standards see here's the thing about
socialism if you actually held to your
standard then you would presumably be
very concerned with giving away a lot of
your money to charity or ensuring that
the amount of money that you made for
your socially useless service
according to marx's theory because of
course your labor
should be judged by some outside metric
that is not the market
so somebody's going to have to explain
by marxist theory why exactly it is more
valuable for a guy to sit around and
stream video games than it is for
somebody to clean toilets
i can explain it because market says
that's what it's worth things are worth
what people say they are worth
but i'm not sure how from a marxist
perspective you can make that case i
also am not sure how you defend a 2.7
million home or a three million dollar
income for doing those things and then
say it's my labor no no that's my
perspective dude if you're gonna do the
it's my labor routine
welcome to capitalism dude seriously
so it is uh it is amusing to watch the
media play this game you're a hypocrite
if you're a right-winger who abrogates
your own principles if you're a
left-wing socialist who earns millions
of dollars for talking online
then you are not a hypocrite in any way
by the way if you're a if you're a
left-wing outlet that rails against the
evils of capitalism while taking
millions of dollars from hedge funds in
youtube you're not a hypocrite either
that's the way this works nobody has to
hold you to account or point out that
you need to if you are if you are young
turks for example
and you attempt to crush your own
unionization efforts right if you're if
you are the the outlet for unionization
unionization is the only thing that
matters and then like a couple of years
ago it turns out that people at your
place are trying to unionize and you
yell at them not to unionize
nobody seems to care very much about
that
and now here's my belief about hypocrisy
you can make the case for hassan or tyt
or who i believe hassan used to be at
cyt you can make the case for all of
these people
that personal activity doesn't abrogate
the principle
now you can make the case that the
marxist principles are correct and you
are living in
in
opposition to those marxist principles
because everybody is a sinner right this
is sort of the religious perspective
they're religious principles about
morals you don't always live up to those
because everybody is a sinner that
doesn't mean the morals are wrong means
you're wrong
but you can't have it both ways you
can't say everything i'm doing is
entirely justified and i'm a marxist i'm
a marxist stalwart while simultaneously
living high on the hog the way that a
capitalist would
here's my capitalist view of all this
congratulations to hassan on earning his
business success i hope he enjoys his
2.7 million dollar house and his 200
thousand dollars of earned income every
month i hope he enjoys it it's the
fullest of his ability and lives a happy
fulfilling capitalist life
same for all of the people over at
places like tyt but please stop
pretending that you are a good marxist
if you don't live like a marxist and
justify yourself in capitalist terms
because that ain't the way this works
at least acknowledge your sins against
the great gods of socialist
redistribution
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video